Tiffany Smith: Please welcome to the stage, first, the executive producer, Todd Helbing. C'mon out here, sir.
Next up, we've got Keiynan Lonsdale, you guys know him as Wally West.
Mr Jesse L. Martin, Joe West!
Next up, you've got Iris West, Candice Patton! Come on out here!
Tiffany: And next up, we've got Barry Allen himself, Grant Gustin!
And next, Harrison Wells. We've got Mr. Tom Cavanagh.
And next, you've got Danielle Panabaker
I don't even know what we're gonna call her yet this season!
Killer Frost? Caitlin Snow?
We'll have to see :)
And finally, we've got Cisco, aka Vibe, aka Carlos Valdes!
We've a got a very good saunter onto this stage
It's still goin', the saunter is still goin'...
I like it a lot...
*chuckles*
Well, welcome everybody. We're so excited to have you here and talk a lil' bit about last season
And, obviously, get into the new season as well..
I kinda want to jump in from the beginning and talk about last season feeling very different
from the other 2 seasons that we had
It got a little bit darker, but for all of you guys on the panel; kinda just jump in...
How much fun was that for you? Or what did you love about kinda going a little bit darker, getting a little more emotional..
Grant: Er...
Tom: Go...
Danielle: So much more fun to be bad...
Danielle: It was fun, I got to be Killer Frost and take it, y'know, a little bit darker, a little bit edgier, that was great!
Tiffany: Well, and kinda jumping off of that and joking about some of the stuff that we saw..
We've seen you go full Killer Frost, we've seen full Caitlin Snow, and I've kinda come up...have come up with a new name
Do you think this new season she's gonna be like "Light Flurries" or something (lol)
Caitlin: That's awesome
Tiffany: Thanks guys, for that laugh.
Great job :D
Where is she gonna be in the next season kind of?
I mean, i don't know.
Who are there likes Caitlin Snow?
(Audience Cheers)
And.. Who likes Killer Frost?
Guys, good news. No one is gonna be disappointed.
(Cheers)
That was a good answer.. politically correct, she didn't give too much away.
Thanks.. I've been practicing all day. I loved it.
So we obviously got full dark from Caitlin Snow Killer Frost last season, also Savitar obviously being the big bad of the season
For all of you guys, when did you know that it was actually going to be a different version of Barry
and how did that kind of impact your acting on the show?
I knew pretty early on
Umm
It didn't obviously affect too much for me, cause Barry, didn't know... Um
But yeah... I knew pretty early on. Didn't everyone know pretty early on?
I think so. Yeah.
We're not good at keeping secrets.